Every time Netflix adds another tween dramedy
to their service, you have to wonder: where
are all the good movies?
Well, they're there — they just take some
digging.
From chilling horror films to quirky comedies,
Netflix is filled with great movie selections
if you know where to look.
Here's a roundup of some of the best Netflix
hidden gems you probably haven't seen yet.
In Order of Disappearance
You'll be rooting for the underdog in this
hard-boiled crime thriller straight from the
snowy streets of Norway.
Starring Stellan Skarsgard and Game of Thrones'
Kristofer Hivju, In Order of Disappearance
follows a quiet, seemingly average snow plow
operator on a quest to avenge his the murder
of his son.
Equal parts pitch-black comedy and explosive
revenge thriller, In Order of Disappearance
is as unstoppable as its protagonist.
As the New York Times' review put it, it's
somewhere between Fargo and Quentin Tarantino,
and the end result is way more fun than it
should be.
"Hello?"
"Well, he can't, he can't actually talk right
now.
Because he's done."
Officer Downe
Let's just preface this by saying that you
shouldn't expect a lot from Officer Downe.
Based on the 2010 graphic novel, the movie
is a hyper-stylized splatter-fest about a
cop who can't die.
Well, he can.
He just comes back to life again.
That's about it as far as plot goes.
There's a criminal organization that dresses
like animals, some gun-toting nuns, and a
clan of ninja-type people, and as you'd expect,
they all take turns trading blows with undead
supercop Officer Downe.
Fortunately, the movie doesn't ask or expect
the viewer to take any of this seriously.
It doesn't even ask you to care all that much
about who these people are — all it really
wants is to have gunfights and explosions,
and in that respect, it does okay.
Just turn off your brain and let Downe take
care of the rest.
Ava's Possessions
Just when you thought the demonic possession
genre had been exorcised of all traces of
originality, along comes Ava's Possessions,
a twist on the trope that looks at life after
a possession happens.
It's a fresh take on the whole possession
thing, drawing a satirical parallel between
people who've been possessed and alcoholics,
support groups and all.
"My name's Ava"
"My uninvited spiritual guest possessed me
for 28 days"
"And was exorcised on Tuesday."
If you're looking for something out of the
ordinary to spend an evening with—or just
in the mood to find some bleak comedy in the
unlikeliest of places—you could definitely
do a whole lot worse.
War on Everyone
For all of its unlikable characters, War on
Everyone is a surprisingly enjoyable movie.
The main characters are Terry and Bob — played
by Alexander Skarsgård and Michael Peña,
respectively — two crooked cops with absolutely
no moral code.
Instead of stopping crimes, they spend their
days blackmailing criminals in exchange for
kickbacks.
This is technically a buddy cop comedy, but
the black humor and overall message that nothing
really matters take it to some weird places.
And yet somehow, by the time the last bullets
have found their mark, you realize that you
kind of like these two amoral sleazebags who
haven't performed one single act of redemption
the whole movie.
War on Everyone won't hit home with everybody,
but if you like dark humor, you may find yourself
enjoying it a little more than you should.
Moon
You may know Duncan Jones as a director from
recent films like Mute or Warcraft, but in
2009, Jones released his debut film Moon,
a low budget sci-fi gem that pulled in less
than $10 million at the box office.
Starring Sam Rockwell and a robot who sounds
like Kevin Spacey, it's the definition of
a bottle movie — just one man in a lunar
research station, slowly losing his mind.
"You guys been to any...good parties or anything?"
Of course, any trailer will tell you that
there's a little more to it than that, but
we're not trying to spoil anything here.
If you've never seen Moon, do yourself a favor
and avoid all the marketing and just queue
it up on Netflix.
A Perfect Day
It was a simple job: just get the corpse out
of the well.
But nothing is ever simple for this group
of aid workers during the Yugoslav Wars.
Beset on all sides by uptight U.N. bureaucrats,
gun-toting kids, and booby trapped cows, all
they want to do is find a piece of rope so
they can pull a body out of a local town's
water supply before it poisons the villagers.
With a cast led by Benicio del Toro, Tim Robbins,
and Melanie Thierry, A Perfect Day is both
an absurd comedy of errors and a low-key satire
of the regulations and red tape involved in
international conflict.
Without making any grand statements, the movie
suggests a parallel between the main characters'
small-scale mission and the larger surrounding
war.
If it's this hard to find a rope, how is an
entire country supposed to figure out its
problems?
Blame!
There seem to be two camps when it comes to
this Netflix animated film — those who like
the original manga hate the movie, and those
who haven't read the manga generally enjoyed
it.
But love it or hate it, when it comes to fresh
takes on the apocalypse, Blame! has most any
other futuristic vision beat, hands down.
That's what makes this film so intriguing.
In a seemingly endless, continually growing
city that goes for miles up, down, and in
either direction, robots have taken to exterminating
humans.
But a small band of people has survived for
centuries inside an invisible shield that
keeps the robots out.
They don't know why the robots can't get inside
their colony; they just know that going outside
means risking life and limb at the hands of
predatory robots.
It's only when a stranger comes to their town
that they realize there may be a chance to
do something about their predicament and finally
stop the expansion of the city.
For vision alone, Blame! is well worth watching.
The Vault
James Franco headlines The Vault as the assistant
manager of a bank that gets knocked over by
a group of petty thieves.
The twist is, the bank is haunted.
When Franco leads this heist gang down into
the underground vault, they get more than
money.
They get ghosts.
You won't be rocking back and forth in terror
from The Vault, although it does have its
chilling moments.
You won't end up rooting for the thieves,
although it does open them up to empathy eventually.
And you definitely won't be chuckling at James
Franco's silly antics, because he's a stone-faced,
mustachioed man on a mission once things really
get rolling.
What The Vault lacks in such departments as
characterization, script, and suspense, it
more than makes up for in ghosts.
Bunches of ghosts.
If you love ghosts, you'll easily tolerate
The Vault.
Cold in July
Starring Michael C. Hall and Sam Shepard,
Cold in July begins with a quiet family man
who shoots a burglar in his house.
Soon, though, his family is being terrorized
by the departed young man's angry father,
who's fresh out of prison and out for revenge.
While that alone would make for an interesting,
if predictable film, Cold in July quickly
switches gears as these two men realize that
there are bigger stakes involved than their
petty revenge tale.
One of Cold in July's biggest strengths is
that you never guess where the story is going
next.
Each new twisted development takes the characters
in an entirely new direction.
If there's a downside to the whole thing,
it's that the ending is over a little too
quickly.
But it's not enough to ruin what's otherwise
a solid, engaging movie.
Oculus
Netflix has a million and a half horror movies,
and the vast majority of them aren't exactly
gems, hidden or otherwise.
Oculus looks a lot like the rest of them when
you're scrolling through Netflix, but with
one teensy, important difference — it's
actually pretty great.
A brother and sister return to the house where
their father murdered their mother, bringing
along the haunted mirror that made him do
it.
Their plan is to record themselves being driven
crazy by the mirror so the whole world knows
that an evil mirror is responsible for that
horrible crime back in the day.
Even the description sounds a little silly,
but Oculus is that one rare gem that pulls
it off.
Oculus was one of writer and director Mike
Flanagan's first films with a decent budget,
and it shows in every frame.
Flanagan has since gone on to direct several
other films, including one of those Ouija
movies that were everywhere in 2016 and Netflix's
Gerald's Game adaptation, so his is definitely
a name you'll be hearing about more often
in the future.
Fullmetal Alchemist
Is the live-action version of Fullmetal Alchemist
as good as the anime?
Not even close.
Is it cheesy and hilarious and full of ridiculous
moments?
Oh, you bet.
For newcomers to the whole thing, the story
is about two brothers with a natural inclination
for alchemy who attempt to bring their mother
back to life.
Things go horribly wrong, and one brother
ends up with his soul trapped in a suit of
armor while the other loses an arm and a leg.
When they're older, they search for the mythical
philosopher's stone in the hopes of restoring
their bodies.
As far as anime adaptations go, Fullmetal
Alchemist is arguably one of the best out
there.
It doesn't cover the whole story, but it serves
as an origin tale and works as a self-contained
story that even non-fans can enjoy.
At least, you can enjoy it if you already
like over-the-top action fantasies.
That's all this is.
Super Dark Times
This coming-of-age story has all the staples
of the genre — high school friends, teenage
drama, house parties, and pubescent angst.
But for two best friends, a traumatic experience
may be too much for them to reconcile.
In his feature-length debut, director Kevin
Phillips has crafted a tight, unique teenage
thriller.
The rich atmosphere and superb performances
from a relatively unknown cast add weight
to an already heavy script.
This isn't an easy movie to watch.
Although other films may be more gratuitously
violent, Super Dark Times doesn't offer a
hint of escapism in its few brutal moments.
If you're looking for lighthearted viewing,
you'd be better off queuing up something else.
But if you want to experience a superb film
with a dramatic message, you could do worse
than Super Dark Times.
A Serious Man
Even by Coen brothers standards, A Serious
Man is an unusual movie.
It starts with a subtitled prologue set in
the 19th century and then moves into a suburb
in the Midwest circa the late '60s.
The main character is Larry Gopnik, a Jewish
physics professor.
"So, am I right?
Okay, so if that's that, then we can do this."
When Gopnik's life starts being derailed by
a chain of events completely beyond his control,
he visits three rabbis to figure out the meaning
of life.
It's not the Coens' best movie by a long shot,
or even their best comedy.
In the end, you'll probably come away scratching
your head.
But maybe you'll also watch it again a year
later, because there's something there, something
you can't put your finger on.
There has to be something holding it all together.
Or maybe, just maybe, none of it means anything.
"Okay - the uncertainty principle.
It proves we can't ever really know what's
going on."
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!